starting off this hour is mark in Texas
hey Mark welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey Dave are you doing better than I
deserve what's up hey I just have a
weird situation with the renter anyway
sorry little nervous here okay
the renter originally paid three months
in advance so that was a starting June
24th as far as June 1st in any way he
ended up passing away June 24th and uh
yeah so uh his you know rent was paid
til September the 1st but his ex-wife
and son haven't picked up any of the
stuff over that period of time and
anyway I just didn't know what my
options were there's something like that
you know have you had any contact with
them yes I have and anyway like I said
they haven't done anything for two
months but you know I guess I just was
showing them some grace and was like hey
if y'all want to you know do we probably
give y'all some more time that would be
fine and it and it has but here it is
September 8th and they still haven't
paid and I you know confronted I'm hey
where's money and she got real
belligerent and basically was like well
you know you're not allowed to get on
the property and you have to do in
fiction process they can take moments
and that's just the way it's gonna be
and you know threaten to sue me stuff
like that okay well she doesn't have any
standing to sue you she's the ex-wife
right well I mean you've been nice and
what you got for it was she's a but so
the way I paid that back is in like kind
I'm gonna get an attorney today and I'm
gonna throw his stuff out there as quick
as the law will allow me to I would have
been really really merciful and kind for
a long time it's horrible the poor man
died oh my god horrible thing but then
when you raise
you know when I'm trying to be nice to
you and your answer is to be a butt back
well we can we can handle that if we
have to it's kind of sad but if you only
if you want dance let's dance so you
know I'd call a lawyer today find out
what your rights are and what the
process is I have never had and all the
years of landlording I've never had to
evict someone who's already passed away
I don't know how to do that I'm not sure
I'm not sure the estate has any standing
since the individuals not living but you
know my guess is that neither one of
these characters even have the money to
get the u-haul to get the stuff out of
the house am i right
yeah it's just a weird situation you
know usually everybody just wants to
come sweep in and get anything of value
and it's just that there is there
anything of value in there oh you know
not really maybe twenty five hundred
bucks yeah yeah more trouble to screw
with it than anything else probably so
well I would ask an attorney if you can
move it into storage and put your house
up rent and then if they decide to sue
you then I would sue them back in return
I don't know if you have to go through
an eviction proceeding I really don't if
I were in your shoes I would ask for
legal counsel and then I would weigh
that against taking my chances and just
putting that in storage you might get
sued though I mean you need to know what
you're up against right but her
threatening me was the end of me being
nice that was the end of it so I mean if
she had said you know gosh we're still
trying to recover our hearts are broken
and I mean he is my ex but I still cared
for him and my sons just tore all to
pieces and can you give us another week
and I would have said instantly yeah no
rent just I'll give you another week but
let's get this thing wrapped up and I
mean you would have been kind right back
you know but the way you get them and
you just get more flies with honey
people it's really not hard